all right
questions for jalen abby chin before we
get started
before we get started guys i want to
address the national anthem
i want to show my solidarity to the nba
and adam silva
for uh allowing us to be able to to
peacefully protest
some of the injustice that we felt proud
of the boston celtics as well
angela davis once said that racism is so
dangerous
not because of individual actors because
it's deeply embedded in the apparatus
i think about that quote a lot when i
think about the national anthem
which was written by francis scott key
who was a slave owner
when we talk about the national anthem
we don't really talk a lot about
um the third verse that was written
which addresses you know
slavery mentions like there's no hope
for
you know a hireling or a slave
but the gloom of the grave so um
racism is so deeply embedded in our
country that people don't even flinch
or even shift at the idea it kind of is
what it is
um it's not the the the protest it's not
the police officers the police brutality
it is
all that is important but it's also you
know the framework
of systemic oppression and uh that's
starting with the national anthem so
i think being able to take a knee is
appropriate and it may not
even really be enough but uh i'm proud
of the nba for being a part
of the right side of
you know of how people
right abby chin
jalen is that what you're thinking about
in those moments
and emotionally what is it like to
be in that arena at that
uh say time again just emotionally
what's going through your mind
during those moments and and how does
that
then translate to get you ready for the
game
um to be honest it really gets me fired
up
you know um because when i think about
that i think about
you know when it was written you know
1812 when the national anthem was
written
and it's 2020 you know now and
we're we're we're honoring the
independence
kind of like the second independence of
1812 but
also we're uh we're not acknowledging
you know
the kind of framework and thought that
was being put into you know
that time period it's a different time
so i understand
you know the uh the
the leisure of having you know a country
that's willing to fight for you for
independence
and willing to fight for your right to
be free all of that comes into my mind
when i hear the national anthem
but it's also people on our soil who
aren't experiencing that same leisure
so also that goes through my mind as
well question in person gary washburn
um in the game the one play where
tatum kind of was trapped and had the
ball and you basically ran up
um because you were free and you just
launched the three
it just seems like that's kind of a
confidence we haven't seen uh before
that's
that's growing and you do that you were
going you knew you're gonna knock down
that shot
i mean can you take us through that
sequence and you just
you knew you were gonna shoot that ball
well uh first and foremost i think we
needed to win
so really that's all my mom was on um we
definitely didn't want to come down here
and start off with two straight losses
um we didn't want to that we wouldn't we
wouldn't be able to sleep good at night
knowing the celtics fan base and how
they would have felt if we lost two
straight
games so um it just we had to do
whatever we had to do to win
mark medina
with all the good work for you and
others
what's your outlook on how changes might
come about within the next year
changes and what specifically well what
what sort of changes
coming in um first
i guess a change in uh the awareness
of people that's around i think it's
enlightening going on
i think people are more aware of
injustices i think it's an information
stage and a lot of people are asking
questions so i think the change in
mindset is kind of recurring
but also like change systemically
whether it's in voting in education
you know equal opportunity in health
care
um etc uh it's a lot of it's a lot of
changes that
need to occur and you know i believe in
small victories
um and things like that but at the same
time you know i think that
if we continue to have these
conversations and people continue
to see the importance of them and uh we
put pressure
we can see change faster than you know
the timeline that you know
people might imagine